[Musique]
aujourd'hui pour réinvestir dans notre
mère c'est de ça dont ils ont besoin ils
ont besoin de zones franches concret
investissements sont on travaille on
fera du régalien l'etat sera là mais
qu'ils sont en sécurité dans les
outre-mer sont très importante donc hors
pouvoir d'achat pouvoir d'achat par le
travail
j'ai choisi de venir visiter la première
industrie de la voie d'eau qui est l'un
des seuls à cannes vous savez vous
pouvez venir ici par les chocs ou
simplification
aider cette production de canne à sucre
religion qui fait vivre mille huit cents
petits planteurs d'ailleurs dans mon
projet il y à la création du baromètre
en
moi ce qui m'agace et les peuples de
france si le peuple de france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]